- We'll see each other next
week at your event, right?
- Yes before we say anything else,
I just want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart,
very much for playing my event.
- Oh, I'm so excited!
- You know, when they asked
me why Kelly Clarkson,
you already know why, right?
- [Kelly] Why?
(singing)
♪ Since you've been gone ♪
(laughing)
(incoherent singing)
♪ Yeah, yeah! ♪
- I don't even know if you remember this,
that's how I sound sometimes,
because I'm like I don't
remember my lyrics.
(laughing and clapping)
- So wait, you gotta explain the event
and what it's supporting,
cause this is really cool.
- Okay, we're supporting kids in need.
You know, we're providing them with,
you know, certain
resources that they need.
For example, when I was coming up,
boys and girls club was
a place for me to go,
you know, have fun and do certain things.
It was also actually the place
where I created the
character known as Shaq,
because I wasn't really good in school,
but they had study rooms.
I wasn't really good at
basketball, but they had gyms.
They even had a music
room where, you know,
I thought I was a rapper at one time.
So, you know the-
- Why limit yourself?
- Yeah, you're right.
- Exactly.
- So, you know, we go,
we're going to support
the boys and girls clubs
and communities and schools.
So again, this is-
- That's so cool.
(clapping)
I thought it was so cool.
- And again, thank you for playing.
- No, I'm literally, I love, I love it.
Honestly, I was like,
oh my God, am I like,
I'm usually like one of those people,
I feel like books, especially
this part of the year,
cause The Voice and everything's
happened at the same time.
I was so excited, I had the day off.
I was like, yes!
- Yes, thank you!
- I love doing stuff like that.
I think it's an important thing,
especially when you're just
such a figure in the public eye
and pop culture and like
using your spotlight for,
for such good.
It's like a superhero power.
- Yeah. I'd just like to,
you know, help kids in need
- Yeah!
- You know, the kids that we're helping
is in 78, 79, that was me.
So, you know, a lot of people
reached out to, you know,
helped me and made sure
that I had certain resources
and certain things like shoes
and books and pencils, you
know, things like that.
So, yeah.
- I was the hand me down kid too.
They used to have like the
trash bag from our church.
They'd have like, they'd
give all the clothes-
- I had those too.
- I grew up with those bags,
which, which was more fun though,
being a rap star or
being a basketball star
because I'm going to say being on stage
with a microphone was pretty cool too.
- You know, for me, it was
about following my dreams.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- You know, I was a medium
level, juvenile delinquent.
And certain times I say, I
want to be a basketball player.
And other times I want to be a rapper.
And other times I want to be a cop
or like, I want to be a supermodel.
Like, you know, all these
things I would say, so.
When I got the opportunity to do a rap,
because I never wanted to be a rapper.
I went the Arsenio hall show,
and I told Arsenio there,
I said, just let me rap
with my favorite rap group.
I did.
And they offered me a six album deal
and I couldn't turn that down.
- Wow!
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. That's amazing.
Here's my thing. I just
say, why limit yourself?
You never know.
Like that's that one movie, is it?
Yes Man, is it Jim Carey?
There's a movie or something-
- Yes, yes, man.
- And I was like, I took that nugget.
I was like, all right.
I started saying yes to stuff
and look what, I have a talk show,
so I would never would've thought
that would have happened
so that you just start
saying yes to things
that you normally wouldn't say yes to.
(clapping)
So how are you at karaoke?
Do you have a go-to song?
- Of course, yeah.
- And I, and I really hope
it's like a show tune.
(laughing)
- Would you like to hear my go-to song?
- Yes, I would.
(singing)
♪ Since you've been gone ♪
(laughing)
(incoherent singing)
- Look at your, my favorite
is the shimmy shake.
(incoherent singing)
(laughing and clapping)
- Okay, wait so, the Gala is in Las Vegas,
so what was the best night
you ever had in Vegas
that can talk about on daytime television?
(laughing)
Cause we've all had ones you might can't.
Yes.
- Then I can talk about, let me see
- Yeah.
- Okay, so when I first got to Vegas,
I went to see Siegfried and Roy,
so I wanted to sit up front
because I'm the guy I like to try
to figure out all the magician's tricks.
So he looks at me and he,
and the tigers on stage,
he looks at me and he says,
I'm going to do something
never seen before.
And he did like that and
when the smoke came up,
the tiger was sitting
on my table like this.
Looking' at me, I was like.
(laughing)
- I bet you weren't
trying to figure that out,
you're just trying to figure out
where your extra spare shorts were.
- Yeah, I was.
He was like, he was right there
in my face and he was looking at me
and I'm looking for
security and other people,
everybody just clapping.
I was like, no, don't clap.
Get the tiger outta here.
He was like right here in my face.
- Don't scare the cat.
- So that was probably the scariest night.
Another time I was leaving Vegas,
cause I'm not really a gambler
I was leaving and you know,
always, always like the
bet on black in roulette.
So I put like $500 down and I won.
- Oh my God.
So I always been on red and
I usually win when I play.
- You do?
- I don't know why, I like red.
- I named a whole album,
had it wrapped in red.
I like the color red,
what's the craziest bet
you were ever a part of
and did it involve Michael Jordan?
Cause I hear Michael Jordan likes to bet.
People keep telling me that.
- No, it was Jimmy Fallon.
- Oh.
- It was a crazy Superbowl bet.
And I said, well, anyway,
I lost, I had to walk five blocks
in the, in a pair of pink thongs.
(laughing)
- Wait, what.
- Yes.
- Look at his face, yes.
- Five blocks.
- Oh my God. What was the bet?
- During Superbowl weekend.
- Oh my god, wait so
that's kinda cold, right?
- Yeah, so it was something like
if my team didn't make
it to the super bowl,
I'll walk five blocks in a pink-
- Oh my god.
- bikini, not a thong, bikini.
- Okay.
- I know some of y'all
pictured the thong, but I don't
(crowd laughing)
- Bikini, bikini.